this age is characterized by just
astonishing technological progress by
the appearance everyday of examples of
science fiction become reality
driverless cars it's important to keep
in mind George Jetson actually drove his
vehicle to work every day so in this
case we're actually out stripping some
examples of science fiction
we've got smartphones that talk back to
us it's kind of like the computer on
Star Trek that would figure out what
Kirk wanted and give it to him we've got
the world jeopardy champion no longer
human being it's a computer these days
so in area after area autonomous
vehicles natural language processing
humanoid robotics speech synthesis
unstructured search we're seeing
examples of science fiction becoming
reality after decades of slow steady
really uninspiring incremental progress
in a lot of these areas the achievements
were seeing now remind me a lot of
Hemingway's wonderful quote about how a
person goes broke he says its gradually
and then suddenly so for me the second
Machine Age is the sudden period that
we're in right now where we've got these
continuous examples of science fiction
becoming reality and from all the
technology geeks that I've talked to the
very clear message that I keep hearing
is all that stuff that you're seeing
today these are not the crowning
achievements of the second Machine Age
these are the warm-up acts we ain't seen
nothing yet
and the innovations and advances that
are going to come over the next few
years over the next decade are going to
continue to just blow us away so why are
we seeing all this progress just in the
past few years and there are three main
reasons for it in our view the first is
the relentlessness and the accumulation
of Moore's law it's to the point now
where the smartphones that we're
carrying around are honestly about as
powerful as the supercomputers of a
generation ago and they're even more
impressive because they've got
touchscreens and GPS receivers and Wi-Fi
transponders and cellular telephone
receivers and accelerometers and
compasses built into them they're just
jam-packed they're these astonishing
collections of digital technology
all of which are made possible by the
steady improvement captured by Moore's
law the fact that digital devices tend
to get about twice as good for the same
dollar every 18 months after that
doubling has been going on for long
enough a difference in degree really
does become a difference in kind we find
ourselves in a new machine age the
second reason is related to the first
it's that a lot of these devices are
putting out massive amounts of data so
we do find ourselves in a big data world
it's not that the quantities of data are
5 times bigger 10 times bigger an order
of magnitude more than we're used to
seeing they're literally thousands or
millions of times greater than we've
seen in the past
my favorite cute example of that is the
fact that in 2012 Cisco released a
report they looked at all the traffic
going across their routers around the
world and they measured it in zettabytes
now we only have one prefix left in the
existing metric system before we run out
of metric system to describe how much
data there is in the world we've got the
yottabyte after that we flat run out so
of course the digital geeks are aware of
this and they've got a working group on
it the candidate they've proposed is the
hella byte so we're gonna head into the
hella byte era before too much longer
the third leg of the tripod for why
we're in the second Machine Age now is a
view of innovation and in this view
innovations are not things that get used
up and therefore we don't benefit from
them anymore every innovation becomes a
building block for subsequent
innovations a great example there the
internal combustion engine has been with
us for over a century we've rung a lot
of the efficiency out of it we've got
millions hundreds of millions of cars
around the world so you think oK we've
got the automotive revolution well stick
a bunch of sensors on that combine it
with a bunch of map data and other big
data from those sensors apply some
pretty serious computational muscle to
it and suddenly we've now got cars that
can drive themselves and they can do it
on roads in traffic not a lab
demonstration out there in the real
world I've had the chance to ride in a
Google completely autonomous car it is a
on experience until it becomes boring
because the car is such a good driver
that by the end of the ride I felt like
I was riding on the monorail that takes
you from your gate to the terminal at
the airport we're going to continue to
see improvement in these kinds of things
and we're going to continue to convert
science fiction into reality